في السودان جدلا واسع اثرته فتوى رئيس
لجنه الاحوال الشخصيه في مجمع الفقه
الاسلامي علاء الدين ابو زيد ابو زيد
اجازه للرجل الزواج من زوجه اخرى دون ان
يخبر زوجته او اسرته مشترطه توفر الشروط
بحضور الشهود في الزواج التصريحات نقلتها
مواقع ووسائل اعلام بشكل كبير في الاوساط
السودانيه وتفاعل معها رواد مواقع التواصل
وشخصيات مجتمعيه معروفه مؤكدين ان المراه
السودانيه ترفض ذلك وبشده كما تزامن
التصريحات وهو ربما ما اثار الموضوع بشكل
اكبر مع تقرير صحيفه الانتباه السودانيه
كشف عن تفشي ظاهره الزواج السري بالشكل
الكبير خلال الفتره الماضيه في السودان
خوفا الاولى
[موسيقى]
شايلين
من الخرطوم تنضم لنا النشطه والمدافعه
الحقوق المراه اميره عثمان حامد ومعهد
الداعيه الاسلامي اسامه سليمان اهلا بكما
معانا في صباح العربيه ابدا معك يا اميره
ما رايك اولا بهذه الفتوى زواج الزوج من
دون علم زوجته
صباح الخير شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه
رايي طبعا انا ضد الفكره تماما لان هي
بتهديم الفكره الاساسيه للزواج اللي هي
المفروض يكون مبني على حسن المعشر والصدق
والامانه والحب والتفاهم اا وعقد الزواج
هو ما وصفه سبحانه وتعالى بالمثال الغليظ
همم فكيف يكون الزواج السردي وهو يعني
بيعتمد على صفات المنافق ثلاث اذا تحدث
كذب واذا وعد اخلف واذا اردتم من خانه وكل
ما يتزوج زواج سريعه يعتمد على الثلاثه هي
الكذب في الوعد يعني
فنحما ضد الفكره تمام واذا في رجل اصلا
اراد ان يتزوج باخرى فليق يقوم بشيعه بما
كان في انه هو يحدث الزوجه الاولى ويصارحه
ويرتب وضعها كما تريد وتعلم وثم ذلك طيب
الموضوع الشيخ اسامه يعني الامر بالاساس
وكانه مبني على خطا مبني على سر مبني على
عدم اشهار بالتالي كيف تنظرون الى هذه
المساله التي اصبحت متفشيه نوعا ما في
السودان
اولا لك التحيه ولكل الذين يشاهدون الان
ويستمعون الينا
واسال الله ان يبارك للجميع ان شاء الله
في كل ما قد اعطاهم منحهم ااه للمعلومه
يعني انا لست متحدثا باسم مجمع الفقه
الاسلامي وانا كداعيه وباحث في الشؤون
الاجتماعيه
كاحد تلاميذ الدكتور علاء الدين عبد الله
ابو زيد الامين العام لجمعيه الامام مالك
الفقيه هي هذه التي صرح بها على السوشيال
ميديا لم تكن فتوى صادره من مجمع الثقه
الاسلامي اولا
ثانيا لم يفتي بها الدكتور علاء الدين عبد
الله ابو زيد انما هي يعني انا لا اريد ان
اقول عدم مهنيه او اقول كذبه يعني عبر
الوسائط واريد بها يعني تشويه صوره
الدكتور او هنا او ما الى ذلك
الامر حدث في انه قل استفتاء الدكتور علاء
الدين عبد الله ابو زيد وهو رجل مالك ونحن
هنا في السودان مالكيه همم الزواج السر
نحن المالكيه وكل الساده المالكيه
المتاخرين والمتقدمين لا يجيزون زواج السر
بل يقولون بفسخه
بفسخه يفسخون هذا الزواج حتى اذا اشترط
الرجل على الشهود او اذا اشترط على همم
يعني ولي الزوجه الثانيه ان يكون هذا
الزواج السريا فانه يفسخ عندنا
ومن شروط الزواج وصحه الزواج وسلامه
الزواج ان يكون معلنا وان يكون يعني
الجميع يعرف هذا الزواج وكما ذكرت
الاستاذه اميره هذا ميثاق غليظ وهو سد
الزراعي اذا كانت هنالك همم احدى الفتيات
ضبطت في مساله غير شرعيه او حب
غير شرعي حبل غير شرعي
فلا ربما يعني
تتوانى او تقول والله قد تزوجت من فلان
سوريين فهذه زريعه من الزرائع قد سدتها
شريعتنا السمحه فلم تكن هذه فتوى باي حال
من الاحوال نحن نقول ان الزواج يجب ان
يكون باركانه وان يكون بولين وان لا تزود
المراه كما قال النبي صلى الله عليه واله
وسلم ايما امراه نكحت من غير ولي فزواجها
باطلبها
يعني معروف انه هذه الظاهره غير متفشيه
وغير طبيعيه في المجتمع السوداني لا
تتقبلها الزوجه وكذلك المجتمع السوداني
مترابط جدا عائليه يعني الزوج يعني زوجه
تكون مقربه جدا لاهل الزوج في هذه الحاله
الا اما ده هكذا ظاهره يمكن ان تؤثر على
هذا الترابط العائلي وعلى المجتمع
والله للاسف الزواج السري هو موجود في
المجتمع السوداني والمفاجاه كثيرا عند
وفاه الرجل ان تاتي في لحظات الفراش امراه
اخرى باطفال فتقول انا كنت زوجته وهذه
الابناء ابنائي موجوده في السودان
قبل المحاكم الشرعيه والحياته بانه يكون
في شرط من الزواج ويكون فيه تسجيل لانه اي
رجل متزوج من كم امراه انه يتم اعلام
همم يعني الزوجات السابقات ما لم يكونوا
عارفينه وزوجها السابعه ما يتم عقد الزواج
اخر يعني هي موجوده في المجتمع السوداني
ولكن الزوج هي تدفع ثمن
الزواج في النهايه بتكون مضطهده في
المجتمع ما بتطالب وان تم الطلاق بها
والنسبه كبيره جدا بيسيب الاستغلال النساء
الوضع هنا الاقتصاد سيء يعني ويكون الرجل
عنده
مالي يعني فبيتزوج سري وبيط
يعني فهي
السند المجتمعي
في ان هي تطالب بحقه وبتكون في وصفه
اجتماعيه معينه بالنسبه ليها يعني
من ضمن الشروط اللي بيحلل بها الزوائد
السريه في السودان
عدد كبير جدا من الاولياء الامور الحاجه
دي في مقابل المال واللي هي جزاتها بتبقى
جزء من من التقطيع للمراه يعني والبقاء
انا حسب رايي يعني يعني
اوكي يعني
ولكن يبدو انكم متفقين وعلى نفس الموجه
شيخ اسامه فبالتالي ساكون انا ضد يعني لكي
نحرك النقاش شيخ اسامه اليوم الا تعتقد
بانه الظروف الاقتصاديه التي يمر بها
السودان تحولات الحياه الاجتماعيه فرضت
كثير من المتغيرات على المجتمع في السودان
وربما تغيير بعض القيم والتقاليد
المتوارثه ما رايك
والله نحن هنا في السودان يعني انا ارجو
ان تزور السودان وان تلتقي بالنساء
السودانيات وان تتعرفي على الاعراف
والتقاليد السودانيه هنالك كثير حقيقه من
الاعادات والتقاليد والاعراف هي راسخه في
المجتمع السوداني بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى
ونحن مؤمنون ايماننا قاطعا ان هذه العادات
والتقاليد من قبلها شريعه سمحه نحن ندين
بها لربنا سبحانه وتعالى في المجتمع
السوداني همم هو مجتمع مسلم بفضل الله
سبحانه وتعالى يراعي حق المراه ويراعي حق
الرجل ويراعي كل هذه الحقوق همم انا همم
استوقفتني كلمه ذكرتها الاستاذه اميره همم
ان همم الزواج يسر يجب ان وان كنا حقيقه
نحن نتفق في هذا الامر لا يوجد ما يسمى
بزواج السر على الاطلاق ونحن كماليكيه همم
لكن انها تريد تشريع هذا التشريع من
المحاكم يمنع الرجل من ان يتزوج حتى
تخطر النساء او تخطى زوجته
فهذه مشكله هذه تخلق حقيقه يعني معضلات
ومشكلات كبيره جدا جدا في المجتمع الشريعه
جوزت للرجل واباحه الرجل ان يتزوج الثانيه
والثالثه والرابع وما الى غير ذلك وله ان
يتزوج يعني من المراه الثانيه ولا يخبر
الزوج الاولى يعني لا اقول سرا لكن ان
يعلنوا ان يشهر ذلك الزواج في في في في
اطاله وفي حدوده ان يتزوج الثانيه والثالث
والرابعه وليس للقانون باي حال من الاحوال
طالما ان هذا تشريع قد جاء من الخالق ومن
الصانع سبحانه وتعالى وهو ادرب بصنعته همم
لا باس يعني ان يتزوج الرجل من الثانيه
والثالثه والرابعه همم ما في مشكله لكن
انه يجيء قانون يقيد همم يعني هذه الحريه
التي منعها الله عز وجل للرجل انه انت لا
تتزوج من الثانيه حتى تاتينا مثلا بخطاب
ممهور من الاولى الاولى لن تعطيه خطاب
ممهوره انما ستلقمه حجرا في راسه اول عديد
من الاشياء التي تثنيه عن هذا الزواج
امر مبارك والزواج امر طيب والتعدد نعم
العنوسه الان انتشرت
اميره تفضلي
ايوه
يعني المبرر سعره والله انا اسامه
اكون دائما
انا قلت اعلامه من باب العلم بالشيء وليس
ان هي التوافق او ترفض لكن هي بعد ما
توافق او ترفض هي بتحدد موقفه هي في ذات
نفسها انها تكون موجوده مع الزوج ده في ذا
فويس في الزواج او لا وضحك يعني وانا في
بالك اتكلمت عن انه هي زوجه ثانيه في ذات
نفسها هي بتدفع ثمن كبير جدا
لها مثلا في نهار همم كله اسبوع مره
وهيكون بعيد عنها وبعيد من اولادها بعيد
من متابعه حياته هي ذاته بعيد من مشاركته
في تربيه ابناءه على فكره شنو من اصلا ما
الزواج هو يعني المؤسسه مبنيه على بناء
اسره لبناء مجتمع سليم فاذا انت ايه تبني
الاسره زعتر على على كذا
يعني حاجات مدسوس على الاخر ومتسوس عن
المجتمع وهي ذات ما تكون فخوره بيك وما
تحضر معك المناسبات الاجتماعيه وما تقوم
موجوده على اساس ان هي زوجه ليه يعني لا
تدفع الزوجه الثانيه
انك انت ما يعني ما بتشجاعه بمكان في انك
انت توضح الحاجه للمراه الاولى يعني زي
انت اصلا يعني
متعدده اختي اختي الفاضله
انا ذاكرت انه بعد ما الرجل يتوفى انا انا
جدي انا
حقهم في الميراث لانهم كانوا متزوجين
لا لكن هذا غير يعني ليس لا يكون مسوقه
باي حال من الاحوال همم
انا كذلك بعض النساء الفاضله
لا توجد علامه التي في العشافيه
لا توجد عداله في الزواج السري جزء من
العداله ذاتك وجودك المجتمعي
واحترامك لذاتك واحترامك ذاته للمراه
المتزوجه الثانيه دي اول الثالثه والرابعه
يعني طيب يعني هنا ما في اي يعني وين خفتم
ان تعدلوا ولن تعدلوا فواحده طيب
بالكذب
والتدليس وهو يعني مرض من البوابه لان هو
بيجيء من الاخر وهدم الفكره بتاعه العداله
ما بين الزوجات
شكرا لك شيخ اسامه